now to the latest on former US Navy SEAL
Edward Gallagher in newly leaked videos
obtained by the New York Times fellow
SEALs who turned Gallagher in describe
him in blunt terms Gallagher was
acquitted of murdering an Isis founder
but he was found guilty of posing with
the dead militant his case gained
national attention after President Trump
restored his rank and prevented any
further punishment
David Martin has more on the seals
accusations statements from Gallagher's
own men describe a Navy SEAL who had
lost all sense of right and wrong on the
battlefield I think he's just the guys
freaking evil man another member of
Gallagher's platoon told naval
investigators in video obtained by the
New York Times SEALs were breaking the
code of silence accusing the man who led
them in combat of war crimes based in
porn on these interviews Gallagher was
charged with murdering a captured Isis
fighter in Iraq but Gallagher's attorney
Tim parla Tory says those SEALs made up
stories just to get rid of Gallagher
they didn't like the chief he was
pushing them too hard they couldn't keep
up and they wanted to get rid of him
they didn't want him to be in charge of
them anymore one of the seals Corey
Scott was granted immunity and testified
the Isis fighter was asphyxiated or
suffocated then came the moment when the
case against Gallagher fell apart he
didn't say that she Gallagher suffocated
after that exchange in which Scott
admitted killing the fighter Gallagher
was acquitted of the murder charge but
convicted of posing with the body he is
now retired and just last week met with
President Trump who had ordered the Navy
not to take any disciplinary action
against him here's the one of the
ultimate fighters tough-guy these are
not weak people these are tough people
and we're going to protect our war
fighters great fighter or freaking evil
the facts are that Gallagher retired
with his full rank as a Navy SEAL
but also with a conviction for violating
one of the laws of war for CBS this
morning Saturday David Martin at the
Pentagon
you